من منفاه الاختياري في لايدن ارسل نصر ابو
زيد بيانا نشرته صحيفه روز اليوسف
محمد رسول الله
وبايمان بنبل الاسلام وانسانيه مقاصده
فانني اود ان اؤكد من جديد انني لم اقصد
بكل ما كتبت الاساءه الى الدين او الطعن
في تعليم الاسلام او قدسيه القران الكريم
او الحديث النبوي الشريف وانما هي في
التحليل الاخير اجتهادات بشريه تخطئ وتصيب
والاسلام الحنيف دينه العلم والعقل
جعل للمجتهدي المخطئ اجرا وللمبي اجرين
واؤكد كذلك انني على اتم الاستعداد
لمناقشه وجاءت النظر المختلفه والمغايره
اذا كان في ذلك في تلك الوجهات ما يقنعني
فانني مستعد للاخذ به لانني لا ارجو الا
وجه الله والعلم الذي ينفع المؤمنين والذي
يتفقوا مع صحيح الدين نص حامد ابو زيد
ثلاثه مارس 1996